it was a week of intrigue and anxiety as
kenyans waited for the presidential
results to be announced
william ruto was declared winner he got
about 7 million votes
his rival railrodinga came second and
immediately disputed the results
as odinga's supporters disrupted the
ceremony chaos broke out
several people were injured some said
they would not let the electoral
commission chair declare the winner
police were brought in to try and calm
the situation it has been a very tense
time both leaders have millions of
supporters so it's going to be
interesting to see how people's
expectations will be managed
seven electoral commissioners sit on the
board four of them have raised questions
about the integrity of the poor they
said they were dissatisfied by the
exercise but only the chair can declare
the winner
we
cannot take
ownership
of the results
that is going to be announced
because
of the opec nature
which these results have been handled
the sacrifices made when things ease up
the new president-elect spoke
striking a conciliatory tone saying he
will work with all kenyans i want to
promise
that
i will
work with all elected leaders
and all leaders in kenya
so that we can fashion a country
that leaves nobody behind
odinga's allies say the paul was not
free and fair many kenyans who support
him are disappointed we would want to
verify them once we verify them we will
be able to know and to tell the kenyan
people because
a result that is not verifiable
is not a result
odinga's next move will be to head to
the supreme court
he has seven days to file his petition
catherine soy al jazeera nairobi